the table below lists some values for  the differentiable function h and its  first derivative define f of x to be the  integral from 0 to x of h of t dt  what is the least possible number of  critical points of f in the interval 2  to 13  0 1  2 or it cannot be determined from the  information given  we want the critical point of f which is  where f prime of x is either 0 or  undefined  we can compute f prime of x by the  fundamental theorem of calculus  f prime of x is equal to h of x we want  to know where this is zero or undefined  so let's focus on this row  since h of x is a differentiable  function it is also a continuous  function so we can apply the  intermediate value theorem when h of x  goes from a positive to a negative value  it must cross zero and when h of x goes  from a negative to a positive value it  must also cross zero so we know there  are at least two points which are  critical points of f and that's the  answer